the truckers revolt in canada is not
just a powerful response to the cruel
destructive madness of corona law it is
the signal of a historic political
realignment the kind that happens only
once or twice a century
it started with trump who refocused the
republican party on the working class
and made it very clear whose interests
he was for
pro-worker pro-worker pro-worker a
pro-worker the forgotten men and women
of our country will be forgotten
no longer
trump delivered on that with pro-worker
policies pro-worker tax cuts pro-worker
regulatory reform pro-worker trade deals
pro-worker initiatives on skills and
training
all of this produced the best results
for american workers in at least half a
century and it completely wrong-footed
the democrats who for decades thought
they were the workers party but as the
elitist woke activist class took over
the democratic party they adopted an
anti-worker policy agenda destroying
energy jobs with extremist climate
zealotry destroying blue-collar earnings
with uncontrolled low-wage migration
destroying workers living standards with
runaway inflation they still tried to
claim they were for the workers
working class and middle class people's
protecting working families every
senator from every state
has witnessed the hollowing out of the
middle class over the past few decades
but now with their response to the
truckers revolt the mask is off
democrats and their stooges in the media
have stopped pretending they hate
workers they really do think that
workers are the deplorables racists
conspiracy theorists basically just come
watch
it's not just truckers there's a lot of
i've heard there's q anon supporters in
the crowd this is much more complicated
than just a small group of people who
are frustrated about vaccine mandates
not when you're waving nazi flags and
confederate flags and having far right
extremists marching in the streets and
threatening local residents it's
a
cult
yes it is
oh yes it is
democrats and their media servants want
to crush the workers first they set the
stage by making them seem dangerous
here's the washington post the movement
shares an affinity with trumpist toxic
authoritarianist is that a word politics
and this from michigan government
gretchen whitmer
well it's dangerous they're inciting and
encouraging people to break the law and
to do so in a way that devastates so
many hard-working people
and then they just come straight out and
say the workers must be crushed this was
from a cnn analyst slash the tires empty
gas tanks arrest the drivers move the
trucks remember these snooty elitists
waging their class war from above who
looked down their noses at blue collar
workers the only reason they're able to
lounge around in their lululemon yoga
pants working from home the last two
years was because blue collar workers
kept their power on and got their oat
milk and weed and vegan sausages
delivered but perhaps even worse than
the condescension and racist smears was
the way they tried to delegitimize a
workers protest as their favorite new
insult and insurrection
where the police chief says covet
protests are a quote nationwide
insurrection driven by madness just
think of the language i know it sounds
familiar to you right a threat to
democracy and insurrection sedition some
of the organizers of this protest which
as i mentioned started more than a week
ago they do want to overthrow the
government you have an insurrection
underway in the capital of a very
important country
when you try to crush dissent by falsely
branding a political protest as an
insurrection
that
is the definition of authoritarianism of
fascism
do the democrats and cnn and msnbc and
all the rest even realize how reckless
and anti-american their rhetoric is we
have to stand up to these bully boy
tactics they're not calling the truckers
insurrectionists because they actually
think they want to overthrow the
government with violent means they're
doing it because they can't stand any
challenge to their ideology there we
know best centralizing technocratic
zealotry they are trying to intimidate
people from challenging them and we must
not allow it to succeed
a key part of that is staying on the
high ground ourselves
that's why it was so self-defeating and
ridiculous for the rnc the other week to
describe the capital right as legitimate
political discourse no it was a riot and
a riot is not a legitimate political
discourse not when antifa does it not
when blm does it and no not when trump
supporters do it either the republican
party has a massive opportunity right
now do not screw it up
as we saw in the 2020 election thanks to
trump the gop is becoming a multi-racial
working-class coalition that is
something we've long argued for here
it will give republicans a political
advantage for a generation
there are more working americans than
there are work from home elitists i know
whose side we're on we always have been
we say it at the top of the show every
sunday we are proudly pro-worker and
proudly pro-america let's make sure we
pursue those aims positively and on the
basis of clear and consistent principle
make sure you share this important
message when we post it we're at steve
hilton x and at nextrev fnc i'm steve
ducey i'm brian kilmea and i'm ainsley
earhardt and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis